hi
it's me i'm andrew garfield and i'm
about to go undercover on the internet
it's actually me
[Music]
what do you think about andrew garfield
10 years from now this is like a matthew
mcconaughey question didn't he do that
at the oscars he was like do you want to
thank my hero it's me 10 years from now
it's like cool
that's amazing what a resource to be
able to go
yeah me that's
great i'm down with that wikipedia
sorry
wikipedia it's wikipedia garfield was a
gymnast this swimmer during his early
years was also an avid
philate
fellatious i don't know about this is it
is it's pronounced philatelist and
that's a stamp collector because
fellatialist sounds
like a different story that i'm not
comfortable talking about this is a
strange thing i've been asked a lot
about it recently so what's the almost
prize stamp i'm like
what
i'm not i'm not a stamp collector oh yes
gymnastics swimmer i was ranked third in
the under 13s 100 meter butterfly in the
southern counties of england also ranked
third
as british schools gymnastics under 13s
one day in training my russian
200 pound
gymnastics coach was sitting on my back
doing a box split and i thought this is
this is not childhood this is some form
of
torture that i wasn't comfortable
continuing
posted arachnologists yuri m marusik and
ali reza zamani honored garfield's
portrayal of the role of spider-man by
naming a new species of crevice weaver
spider preether garfield i after him i
believe that's true pretty cool garfield
it's like it makes me sound it's a kind
of italian but my original name was
garfinkel like my family's name was
garfinkel so it's funny from garfinkel
to garfield to garfield garfield
garfield eye maybe he's garfield eyes
it's latin never mind having completed
the spiritual exercises of ignatius of
loyola for silence he said
what was really easy was falling in love
with this person was falling in love
with jesus christ that was the most
surprising thing i'm surprised to read
it and it's the truth i i had a very
different relationship with the concept
of christ and i'm pleased to say that i
like him i love him i would go so far as
saying he's a pretty brilliant
man
when he was alive and still remains an
amazing spiritual symbol of simple stuff
you know like goodness loving thy
neighbor doing unto others as you would
have them do unto you apply
uh reddit
reddit ready for reddit i'm not ready
for reddit alright so this is the
ticktickboom official teaser complex
sapien 20 says wtf question mark andrew
garfield can sing
yeah yes define sing yeah sure i can i'm
not tone deaf and i trained a lot for
this and it took me about a year and a
half to get my chops up as it were and i
had a lot of help and support and a
coach and i've always wanted to learn
how to sing properly and and this was
definitely the opportunity to do that
replied
you fat and stupid
says
once with andrew garfield simultaneously
starring in two based on true story pro
christians said in japan movies silence
and hacksaw ridge what's with that
what's with andrew garfield doing this
what right does he have who does he
think he is doing films that are set in
japan two in a row and about
christianity
wha what's what's his deal why are you
angry at me you fat and stupid like i'm
not calling you fat and stupid i'm just
calling you by your name
um don't do it why
like it's my choice my life it just
happened that way there were these two
projects that i read they both happened
to be set in japan i happen to play a
catholic and a seventh-day adventist in
both there are spiritual quest things
and they've just appealed to me you've
got better things to do than like
debate with yourself or other people who
don't care about what i'm doing with my
life what are you doing with your life
you fat and stupid you're not a fan
stupid
you're sweet you're probably a sweet
person if we were in the room together
we would have a nice conversation but
this is not the way to talk
about to me about my life and my work
love you next there's a picture of me as
a child and i'm wearing a little
spiderman costume that my mother made
for me out of felt and it's
epic since everyone is discussing suit
ideas might i say this suit being worn
by a kid andrew garfield is my pick my
mother would be very very complimented
by that i agree this that would be the
coolest my mother's felt suit awesome
twitter
it's me for real seriously tomi aguaya
was the best peter parker he was not a
good spider-man though he's got the best
spider-man but was way too cool to be
peter parker tom holland is just the
average for both which makes him the
best because he's the only one that is
decent at both
okay
cool man fine whatever like cool that's
your opinion bro climb a tree toby is my
favorite right because that's my
childhood i think i watched that first
spider-man film back to back like three
times with my friend terry mcginnis
and we were just incredibly high and we
would like prac we would like do the
lines to each other and he just was
cracking up in my face
saying you'll never play spider-man and
uh and now sam
now sam here we are
[Music]
at genghis khan 17 says someone put the
idea of andrew garfield playing joker
for patton since batman and i was
watching the social network mainstream
and silence i have to say i'm very
interested in seeing him be a joker
no no way i wouldn't go near it would
not go near it but sweet of you to think
that it's possible that i don't think i
could ever do it because of what heath
did what jack nicholson did and but then
of course joaquin's just like
did his own genius thing
uh holly berry
underscore 24 says how does andrew
gotham still have a voice at the end of
angels in america part one so much
shouting crying face yes
i don't know how i did it how anyone
does that play it's it's it's a crazy
play and the angel comes in and has sex
with me and
yeah wild that would make sense to
people who have seen the play otherwise
you're going to be confused by that
at nate fleming says i would love to
know how andrew goffel makes his acting
choices he's playing jim baker in the
new film he played a priest in science
he played the devout soldier in hacksaw
rich i wonder why he's drawn to these
roles you know i like to stretch i like
to stretch
my consciousness and i like to feel as
much empathy for as many people alive as
possible and i think that's what pretty
what draws me to this range of people i
like to feel like i'm being challenged
that's that's just me
i feel like stephen colbert will be a
great kisser i wonder if andrew garfield
thought so too
yeah
now on to cora now to quora
now on to quora why does andrew gravel
appear on television shows talking with
a british accent it's just to to to keep
you on your toes it's because i'm
english like why would
no people do do that though don't they
like madonna has this weird and didn't
britney spears for a while have a
british accent my father's american um
so i have had his semi-weird hybrid
british american accent in my year or my
life so maybe that's why i have easier
time getting into an american accent but
yeah no i um this is my accent
or is it no it is how would mcu iron man
treat andrew garfield spider-man i that
everything andrew garfield spider-man
would be pretty
suspect of mcu-iron man i think he would
be a little turned off by the excess the
billionaire trillionaire status of iron
man i think it would rub
my version of spider-man the wrong way
but you know maybe there could be some
influence there maybe
my peter parker could wake tony stark up
to his own egoic drives a little bit
we'll never know
literally never know
what do i think about andrew garfield 10
years from now
hmm
god i don't want to go into existential
crisis on camera
so stop it cora i i think i'll have
children at that point i don't want to
be too old and have children i'll be
tired i'll i will be 48.
that's all that's all i'm gonna say
that's that's a terrifying concept it's
actually me
was andrew garfield so meth at the
social network that he doesn't have any
social media i had a facebook page for
like a month
and then we did that film and i
instinctively just deleted it and
everything else i have a feeling so i'm
thankful for that experience for many
reasons but also because it kept me off
of um
that hell hole
what influenced andrew garfield to
become an actor to be honest it came
from a period of real
lostness when i was a kid and i kind of
let everything fall away i gave up the
gymnastics i gave up the swimming i was
escape punk kid listening to rage
against the machine and
bc boys and like watching skate videos
and
smoking too much weed and i was lost i
was like a lost angsty kid i was like
this can't be it this can't be what life
is it can't just be the stuff that
you're a doctor or you're a lawyer or
you're in business and otherwise you're
kind of like whatever like like the arts
just weren't a thing one value i always
loved movies i'd never been to the
theater and then
it was my mother my mother was like have
you thought about something creative and
artistic because she could tell i was
struggling and i tried everything i
tried painting sculpting music
everything it was fine but then the last
thing i think i tried was the theater a
theater
class outside of school and that's all
and that's that was it it was like the
doors of perception opened up and i was
like oh this is where this is where this
is where it's at for me
youtube
top 10 pivotal moments from the social
network
spinstazz
says the acting here is that much more
amazing when you think about how fincher
made them do it millions of times and
usually salk in demands word for word
how do these actors do it so there's
something about how fincher works
where actually doing it millions of
times means you
you you have it in your bones and in
your body in such a deep way that you
don't have to think anymore and you're
just present with your fellow scene
partner and it creates these very
lived-in
simple truthful performances and then
you're working opposite great actors
like jesse eisenberg and you just tune
into each other and it becomes this
alive unconscious kind of dance you know
when you repeat a word over and over
again it becomes meaningless and then
like you lose yourself like that's what
finch is looking for so actually there's
a method to that madness
[Music]
god damn it jimmy why didn't you ask him
about the video instead of the photo i'd
love to see what he'd come up with to
dodge that this is about um
this um this spider-man
photoshop thing
um that we talked about on jimmy fallon
listen at this point people just ha like
i'm i'm done like we'll all find out
when the movie comes out and we'll
either be very disappointed or we'll be
very happy or like someone will say i
told you so another person will say but
i told you so we'll all find out i'm
sorry in advance
next all right take talk now i actually
i don't have tiktok i i actually don't
have any of these or i might have
instagram but it's like
secret i have like one follower and it's
like my best friend
and we just share like pig videos or
whatever
it's actually me
so we have an image it's of three
spiderman suits toby's mine and tom
hollands andrew garfield 83 says which
one do you think had the best suit um i
out of these three
i actually like tom's one the best but i
like the one for amazing spider-man 2
the best i think as well
all right i don't want to do any more um
that was lovely though i had a good time
thanks for coming along on this wild
ride see you next time on this this
thing bye
forever